- 140 years ago, the
Callander and Oban railway,
in the south-west of Scotland,
set up a rockfall detection system
along four miles of remote
hillside railway track.
The astonishing thing is:
that system is still in operation
today, 140 years later.
And so far no one's been able
to come up with anything better.
- The West Highland lines
travel hundreds of miles
along natural mountainsides.
There are different hazards
depending on where you are
on the Scottish rail network.
Through the Falls of Cruachan,
the hazards there
are definitely rockfall and boulder fall.
We're now at Bridge of Orchy
on the West Highland line
and the hazards here are
much more natural landslides
and debris flows down the
steep-sided mountains.
Rocks that are very small can
pose a risk to the train operations.
So something as small as a microwave
can cause a train a problem.
Something as big as a washing machine
could lead to derailment
so it is a really serious issue.
Definitely stopping the hazard at source
is the best option for us.
In a typical year we will
spend somewhere in the region
of £40 million, and that's on things
that prevent landslides
or improve the resilience
of our infrastructure to extreme weather.
- Thank you very much!
- So Scotland's railway is
about 3,500 track-miles.
So we can't protect that whole length,
so we need to look at other
ways of keeping the trains safe,
which is where the rockfall
detection comes in.
- By modern standards,
it's a really basic system.
There's no electricity.
Just these wires along the
track, held under tension,
mechanically linked to the signals.
If a big boulder falls down,
it hits a wire, the wire snaps,
the tension's released,
and the signal at each end of that bit
of wire changes to show danger.
Repeat for 17 signals over
the four miles of railway.
The system was nicknamed
Anderson's Piano after its inventor
and after the humming noises
that the wires sometimes
make in high winds.
- Anderson's Piano is a
very old system, 140 years.
Keeping something like that
going in a modern environment,
it is quite challenging.
Firstly, I guess there's the knowledge.
There's not a user manual
or a downloadable book
on how to maintain Anderson's Piano.
We need to pass that
down through generations
of technicians and engineers.
And then there's just
getting hold of the kit.
A lot of it was bespoke, made in
foundries in the Victorian era.
Some of it we've had to improvise.
Some of it is just
availability of material.
So getting hold of some of the wire
can be quite challenging.
And we think we've managed
to find a reasonable source
that is a good enough match.
The kind of rural fence that
will use that kind of wire,
the manufacturers are striving
to make it stronger and stronger
and we don't need it stronger
for Anderson's piano.
We need it to break when
there's a rock comes through it.
It's not perfect detection
in terms of screening out.
So vegetation can trip it off,
animal movements if they
do get inside the boundary.
Very manual to reset.
It's a physical task that
involves lifting weights
and repositioning counterbalances
and manually moving
signals back into place.
So we can't do that when
the trains are running,
so that's disruptive to our network.
It's a physical job that
involves human beings.
There's not a big reset
button that we can push.
The first we know there's a problem
is when the signal goes up
and normally the first person to see that
is the train driver.
We are not able to respond someone
to the problem when it occurs.
We need to wait until after it's occurred,
because the first time we know
about it is when a driver tells us.
- Modern rail safety rules
mean that ideally,
no one should ever drive a train
past a signal that's set to danger.
If that is ever needed
because of a fault somewhere,
it requires checking and double checking with central control.
If a train goes past a danger
signal without permission,
there's always an investigation.
If it was because the
driver was negligent,
it can end their career.
But the rules for these
signals have to be different,
and they go against everything
that a modern train driver learns.
If these signals are at danger,
you slow the train down
to walking pace,
to a speed where you will be able to stop
before you hit any obstruction,
and you radio it into central control...
but you do continue.
And that would never be
allowed on a new system.
- It's offering us a level of protection,
so there's a line of defence there
that works quite a lot of the time.
It would be less safe without it.
Prevention is better than detection,
so stopping the rocks
falling is definitely better
than detecting them
when they have occurred.
So we put a great deal
of effort into containing
some of the rocks on our cuttings
and into catching boulders
through high-strength,
high-capacity catch fences that
are anchored into the rock.
We employ all sorts of
techniques like netting,
and meshing, and doweling to
hold all the rock in place.
We're constantly looking for technology
to improve safety on the railway.
Satellite technology that looks
for ground movement from space,
and does change detection on that.
We've tried "listening fibres"
through fibre-optic cables
that listen for an acoustic
signature of a rock falling
or a tree falling on the railway.
The cost of that equipment
is starting to come down.
We're starting to see
advances in technology
which is making it more
affordable to deploy.
But one of the big issues
is actually power.
These things will either
need a power supply,
which in remote places
can be hard to come by,
or they'll run off batteries
and solar panels
which need to have sufficient capacity
to keep them up all year round.
Scottish winters can be quite dark.
Some of our trials have been hampered
by false alerts and false alarms
and too many false alerts
to run a railway.
At Bridge of Orchy we've
got some detectors in place
to capture any movement.
Now, they're the wireless tilt meters
that tell us if the ground's moving.
Like your spirit level on
your iPhone that moves about,
they will detect a bit of movement
and we will get an alert or
an alarm remotely from that.
We've then got a camera on site
that we can see the site
to see whether it's a false alarm or not,
so we're not needlessly stopping trains.
We've got some infrared kit on there
so that we can see at nighttime.
Then infrared reflectors to
see if there's been a problem
during the hours of darkness as well.
It's all remote back to base
and it only requires a
technician in our control centre
to watch that and monitor that.
It's also less prone to false alarms
and we can reset it at
the touch of a button.
So we know about it
before the train comes,
we can capture the problem
before it manifests itself on the railway,
and we can remotely reset
it and remotely monitor it.
We do an awful lot, but it's
not enough to go everywhere.
And, you know, we can't physically
protect every mile of railway.
It's just impracticable.
- From talking to the folks here,
I'd say that the best
description of these signals
is that they are a
frustrating, imperfect system
that's still better than nothing.
Back when I was researching
this video, I figured
that there must be a better solution,
and with all the confidence of
someone in the YouTube comments
who's only watched half the video,
I thought, "Hey, couldn't they just?..."
And no. They can't, at least not yet.
[train rumbling]
How's that for timing?!